قبل قليل اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال مخيم
الفوار جنوب الخليل باعداد كبيره من
الاليات العسكريه والجنود المشا الذين
داهموا الشارع الرئيسي في مخيم الفوار
جنوب الخليل
والمداهمة اصابه اربعه جنود واستشهاد
المنفذ انذا قوات الاحتلال في هذه اللحظات
تتواجد في منزل الشهيد عمار ابو حسين حسب
شهود العيان والاهالي الجيران القريبين من
المنزل تحدثوا لنا قبل قليل عن سماع اصوات
خراب وتكسير في المنزل واصوات صراخ هذا
ياتي بالتزامن ايضا مع اعتلاء جنود
الاحتلال القناصه اسطح العمرات في مخيم
الفوار جنوب الخليل ولا تزال حتى هذه
اللحظ لحظه تداهم المخيم كما ذكرنا باعداد
كبيره بالتزامن مع اقتحام مخيم الفوار
جنوب الخليل داهم الاحتلال ايضا في هذه
اللحظات بلده الشيوخ شمال شرق الخليل وحتى
هذه اللحظه المعلومات تشير الى تفتيش عدد
ومداهم عدد من البيوت والمنازل في منطقه
الشيوخ شمال شرق الخليل هذا جاء بالتزامن
ايضا مع اقتحام قوات الاحتلال او نيه قوات
الاحتلال واعلان جيش الاحتلال هذه الليله
بشكل رسمي عن نيته هدم منازل الشهداء
الثلاثه عبد القادر ونصر الله القواسمي
وحسن قفيشه الذين نفذوا عمليه اطلاق نار
عند حاجز النفق في الساب عش من نوفمبر
الماضي والتي ادت الى مقتل جندي واصابه
سبعه اخرين كان الاحتلال بالامس داهم
منازلهم ووضع ملصقات على ابواب هذه
المنازل ابلغهم فيها القرار بالهدم وقال
ان لديكم يومان للاعتراض على هذا القرار
يوم غد س تنتهي هذه المهله وكان جيش
الاحتلال هذه الليله اعلن بشكل رسمي عن
نيته هدم المنازل الثلاثه في مدينه الخليل
والواقعه في منطقه دائره السير في مدينه
الخليل اذا الابرز والاهم اقتحام مخيم
الفوار الشيوخ والمداهمة